you have someone who's inherently and
then ng vampire in your life if you're
trying to get your act together it's
really important to stretch yourself out
and and sit up properly please
understand that mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our opinions
are controllable what's that belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's live your best believed life and
learn how to get rid of negativity also
if you want to know what Mark Cuban
Jordan Peterson Gary Vee and others have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I've always been
passionate some people thought you know
it's a it's more OCD than anything else
if you're gonna speak effectively you
have to know way more than you're
talking about the reason people don't
put themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one protect yourself from energy
vampires with Dandapani you have someone
who's inherently an energy vampire in
your life some people consume tremendous
amount of energy that's what a vampire
that's right bytes in than I can suck
the life out of you
think there are three types of people
there are uplifting people there are
neutral people and they are not
uplifting people let's define what this
is an uplifting person I spent five
minutes with an uplifting person I walk
away I feel great and go like wow that
was an amazing conversation a neutral
person I spend five minutes with them I
walk away I'm still the same a non
uplifting person I spent five minutes
with them I walk away and I go like oh
my god that was exhausting all right and
you probably experienced that in your
life the next question is are they a
transient energy vampire or inherently a
ninja grandpa right
what's a transient energy vampire to say
John is going through a hard time in
life because his dad is dying of cancer
for example and for three years this
consumes a lot of energy you know he's
always down you need to uplift him he's
feeling very sad it's okay
you give him that energy because he's
your friend and that's what we do we
express compassion empathy and love and
we support our friends during difficult
times what someone who's inherently an
energy vampire someone who's inherently
energy vampires are always been this way
for decades Cesar's haven't changed this
is not an uplifting human being at all
my guru taught me the best way to do
this is to practice the art of being
affectionately detached so the concept
of being affectionately detached is to
not engage with someone right is to be
kind to be gentle to be sincere and
loving towards them by not engaging with
them what's another way to protect
yourself from an energy vampire is to
place the burden of responsibility on
them they fulfilled their task and come
back to you then go out of your way to
help them to treat energy the same way
you treat money it's a finite resource
that needs to be wisely managed wisely
reallocated and wisely
in five to ten percent of my energy and
I gathered to John that's ten percent I
could have given to my spouse my
business the things and people that I
loved energy has no ability to
discriminate between what's positive and
what's negative if I took a watering can
and I watered a garden bed with the
weeds grow the flowers grow both right
water has no ability to discriminate
between the weeds and the flowers
whatever I water starts scrub energy
it's the same way as well if I took
energy and I invested it into something
negative it will grow and become more
negative if I took energy invested it
into something positive it will grow and
become more positive whatever you invest
energy into starts to grow and manifest
in your life
rule number two use the six months rule
with Mel Robbins I've got a great
question about dealing with
relationships friendships where you have
a close friend who's a real downer and
they've got all kinds of issues and they
are draining the you-know-what out of
your energy it happens all the time I'm
gonna say a couple things about this I
have something that I call the six month
rule for the people in your life your
friends your family people are gonna go
through ups and downs and I think it's
super super super important that you be
there for people that you listen to the
things that they're struggling with that
you give advice that you help them find
resources you must must must do that
this is part of being an incredible
friend however when the issue sticks
around so long that your friendships
spirals into a situation where that
friendship is nothing more than you
listening to somebody complain and now
it's zapping your energy now it's time
for you to change how you're behaving in
the friendship so this is why I call it
the six month rule for six months
absolutely listen to somebody give them
all the advice be the shoulder they cry
on let them Beach and kovitch and all
that stuff to you all day long but if
after six months your friend is still
complaining and doing nothing
and is still complaining and acting
helpless is still stuck in that rut and
refusing to take your advice it's really
important that you draw some boundaries
and it's important for you it's also
important for your friend so here's what
you're gonna do you're basically just
gonna say look I love you I know you're
going through a hard time but I will no
longer listen to you complain about it
and the reason why is because it's not
helping you and it's really starting to
make me sad that you're still this stuck
and you're not taking action let's
definitely hang out let's spend a lot of
time together but we're not allowed to
talk about this anymore the second you
start taking action to fix the situation
we can talk about it again and you know
that I'm here for you but I'm not here
for you so that you can stay suck I'm
here for you so that you can get better
so that you can grow rule number three
stand up straight with Jordan Peterson
people in general now have very poor
posture yeah very bad for them well
that's that's got to be phone related -
right well yeah that's part of it but I
also think it's something our culture
doesn't attend to like you kind of have
to remind your kids to stand up you know
it takes a certain amount of conscious
effort but yeah I not chapter I talk a
lot about lobsters which I'm kind of I
kind of have an affinity for lobsters
and because they well the short story is
that when a lobster loses a fight
because they're fighting all the time
for dominance let's say in their
hierarchies he kind of crunches down so
he looks smaller when he wins a fight he
stretches out looks bigger and so he's
signaling to other lobsters the telli of
his victories and then say so if a
lobster has won a fight he's more likely
to win the next fight then you would
calculate from having a tally of all his
previous defeats and victories and if he
loses a fight that he's more likely to
lose the next fight so that's that that
Mathieu principle at work okay so you
think well so what so what does that
have to do with anything it's like okay
part of the kicker is well that lobster
runs on serotonin neurochemical and if
the lobster loses the serotonin levels
go down and if he wins the serotonin
levels go up and when the serotonin
levels go up he stretches out and he's a
confident lobster and one of the
consequences of that is if a lobster
loses about
and you give him the equivalent of
antidepressants then he stretches out
and he'll go fight again so
antidepressants work on lobsters huh
right and you think well who cares it's
like no no you don't get it we diverged
from lobsters from an evolutionary
perspective 350 million years ago and
it's the same circuit it's absolutely
unbelievable and that shows you how deep
inside you how basic how primordial that
circuit isn't you that's sizing other
people up and looking at where they fit
in the hierarchy well with human society
it's more like hierarchies of competence
than dominance per se but and like if
your serotonin levels fall you get
depressed you crunch forward and and the
whole everything around you turns cloudy
and black and and then you're inviting
more oppression right and so you get
into this bad loop you know and so it's
really important to if you're trying to
get your act together it's really
important to stretch yourself out and
and sit up properly because it's it's
part of the psychophysiological loop
that can start you on the upward curve
and so it's a really important thing to
take note of rule number four change
your environment with Gary Vaynerchuk
I'm getting more and more intrigued by
mindset because I used to think of it as
fluffy like self-help and now I think
I'm a bit more as strategy what's your
strategy in life somebody asked me on
Instagram after I posted a scary if the
mindset has been skewed how can you
bring it back and I answered with by
surrounding yourself with people who
have the mindset you aspire to my
friends please understand that mindset
is controllable in the same way that all
our opinions are controllable the key is
to add more people with optimism and cut
people with negativity it's very very
simple now it's very hard to cut people
with pessimism cynicism and negativity
when they are the people that are the
closest to you parents siblings spouse
but the bottom line is if you're asking
the question I'm gonna give you the
answer the answer is add more people
with positivity and optimism and cut
people with pessimism and cynicism
you surround yourself matters what
content you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offense and optimism and now I
know no different please do the same for
you make that move mold and I mean mold
your mindset by what you consume and
with whom you consume it and rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is study success with Les
Brown what do you say to someone while
seeing oh nobody around me believing in
me and that's okay if you have that
that's great if you don't have it yeah
it's okay
I for years read books of people who I
didn't know but I considered them at my
personal mentors right yeah I said it
Winston Churchill who said the truth is
contrary incontrovertible malice mere
tacit ignorant they derided but at the
end there it is I said it Earl
Nightingale who said all of us get in
life what we are not what we want all of
us are self-made but only the successful
will admit it so I studied these people
and they mentor to me I feel their
spirit sigh I surrounded myself in my
bid with their dignity and their law do
in my imagination and listening to their
audio programs yes so how much does a
library call Cod costs it's free in the
United States I don't know what in your
country so I suggest that you spend time
working on yourself study the high
achievers I did that to find out how did
they get there I study the life of
Frederick Douglass who say we won't get
everything that we fight for but
everything we get it will be a fight and
so as you study these people and imagine
yourself in their position and in your
minds I say to yourself as I did if they
can do it I can do it they put their
pants on one leg at a time they breathe
air just as I do and so I believe that
what you would you focus on the longest
becomes a strongest what we think about
we bring about when you train your mind
to serve you yes by reading a minimum of
20 to 60 pages
listening to audio programs writing goes
down reaching reading them three times a
day
you're literally creating a new mental
blueprint and imagining and seeing
yourself already living from the goal
you begin to do some things that would
most people look at it and see is
magical
I've got a really special bonus clip on
how to fend off negativity with marie
forleo that i think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what's one change you'll make to your
environment this week number two which
three energy vampires do you need to
protect yourself against and number
three which three successful people will
you start to study
I want you to fend off negativity as
much as humanly possible you know we
know so much more about the brain than
we did just 20 years ago neuroscience
has taught us incredible things like
that our brains are continuously shaped
by our thoughts and our experiences and
you know this to be true
I mean negativity is one of the most
toxic forces on the planet it's toxic
for your brain for your nervous system
and for your ability to stay motivated
so do me this favor okay do not solicit
or listen to the opinions of people who
are notorious for just being Debbie
downers the one mistake that I've seen
people make consistently is they almost
habitually talk to the exact person who
is the most likely to shoot them down
and make them feel like crap so don't do
that and here's another key I want you
to always always always consider the
source meaning don't put a lot of stock
into other people's opinions unless
they're actually out there consistently
taking risks and being brave and
actually making things happen I mean if
you think about it let's say I don't
know you wanted to climb Mount Everest
would you ever take advice from someone
who's never even attempted the summit no
of course not that would be crazy
so don't take advice from anyone unless
you really think it through and I want
you to ask has this person achieved an
unrealistic or impossible dream are they
taking meaningful risks on a consistent
basis do you admire who they are how
they live and what they contribute if
not do not use them as a sounding board
for your idea
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be can like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want to learn the number one
skill that you have to master in the
21st century check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
rich people were always learning we're
asking questions we are listening we are
reading books